foreign
[Music]
hello hi Daniel how are you doing I am
doing great I'm just enabling
I just fired up my stream can you hear
me all right I can hear you
great fantastic
so what I'm gonna do la Adventure going
so far uh pretty good just uh chilling
with family which is always fun
um obviously traveling given my like
commentary job is always a challenge and
West Coast hours commentating I feel
like rules out any West Coast move for
my like future career I know because you
just have to wake up so early it's not
worth it
it's total yeah it's crazy it was it's a
six hour call time today so I appreciate
you finding time but I'm really excited
me too no this is me too and also I'm so
glad your mom doesn't dislike me anymore
I think I told my chat Dania and I went
to the same University and we were
studying for an exam together and when
he went to the bathroom he left he's
been on Facebook and I thought it would
be fun to post a troll status because
that's what you know crazy college kids
do back then
um but the crazy status I decided to
post was that he was quitting chess
obviously joking but some people took it
seriously and his mom was not so happy
about it my side is that you posted it
we laughed about it
um and I kind of forgot to delete it I
think that night I thought it was funny
um and in fact I didn't delete it on
purpose because I thought it was funny
so I wake up at whatever hour I would
wake up in college you know noon
and I checked my phone and there's 10
missed calls from my parents and of
course you think it's a God forbid it's
an emergency so I'm gonna run out of bed
you know call you know what's going on
we checked your Facebook you know what's
happening I'm like what's happening I'm
like half asleep I'm happy nobody died
you know and it turns out my parents
took that seriously my chest coach at
the time took it seriously and he had
like thrown a fit and it was just like
insane and you know I feel bad Alex that
like my parents got mad at you
ultimately was my call and I still think
it's hilarious
so you are forgiven permanelli by my mom
no no she's
looked past
um and and while you set it up I'll let
chat know a little bit so this actually
started a few years ago probably back in
2019 where we wanted to do this video
series that shows the difference between
someone who's around Master Level myself
and a grand master Dania and of course
now actually a lot of people are doing
these series on YouTube but we did it
for chess.com a few years ago and we've
been planning to do it and now we're
finally able to get together so what we
are going to be doing today is looking
at positions and then I'm will give you
my interpretation of it and then we'll
give you dania's interpretation of it so
that you can kind of see the difference
in level and hopefully it should be
educational so that you see what kinds
of things that you miss
that's a great description I think this
type of content is under in general I
think chess content originality kind of
moves slowly where someone discovers a
format and then everybody does it for
like years you know like going over a
game for example but there's a bunch of
different types of content that are kind
of underutilized and one of them is just
like discussing positions not everything
has to be you know like a super
closed-ended
um neatly organized process because
that's not how like chess thinking
actually works and you want to emulate
you know the realistic situation that
you face during the game so I'm super
excited about this I think that if this
becomes a successful series we can
basically do this with different types
of positions so some of the positions
that I had prepared and are my desktop
computer back home are more open-ended
and positional in nature today
um if you're fine with that I'm thinking
we can start with a more tactical
situations that do have like a clear
solution and then if we uh if it goes
well we can sort of move from there to
more open-ended positions uh that are
more sort of discussion based so for
today I'm thinking that we can kind of
solve a couple of positions together I
have not solved any of them so these
will be new to me as well but I'm pretty
excited about them how does that sound
in general
that sounds good I think one thing we
should uh figure out is do we want to be
solving them independently so that you
can compare compare the process or do
you want me to solve it first since I
will obviously miss things that you
would have seen so I as I said there's
two there's also the choice of like in
the future I can also select positions
whose solution I know and just sort of
monitor your thought press but I think
it is more interesting if I haven't seen
the positions before because that way
like I will also be making mistakes so
there's almost a meta hierarchy where
like maybe I'll correct some of your
mistakes you'll correct in my mind uh so
I think we should probably solve it uh
maybe there should be like a period of
like a minute or so where we just think
and then we come together and you can
just sort of start by describing your
thinking process and all be sort of
adding in some of my thoughts and
correcting you as I go along how does
that sounds good and we can always
change it I think chat should understand
that this is a work in progress
is going to be enough for me but I'm
but so I sent you an invite by the Wayan
chess.com
um you should get a classroom invite
perfect let me give you all the rights
and privileges give full control
now probably kick me out if I misbehave
awesome
hey can you see my arrows I can I can
did you
did you sorry and I just deleted it you
see I'm already misbehaving already
displaying my toxic nature I also wanted
to say Alex that confuse you of that
notion oh I remember that word I think I
used it in commentary every time we used
to do commentary together I would learn
some new words from Donya and
did major in history so I did and this
man would study less than me and still
get higher grades
I'm pretty sure just maybe in one
Humanities class your sample size is
pretty small
but okay we'll have we'll have to talk
about that later yeah sorry let's get
started no no no so you will have to
sort it out afterward who had the higher
GP no just kidding so last thing I
wanted to say Alex just more for like
the Chapman for anything which is to cut
us a little bit of slack because I think
it'll take us some time to get into the
groove but I really do think that
there's a lot of promise to this project
so I really appreciate that you sort of
got the ball rolling again and we'll do
our best
I I did have to ping you on multiple
platforms that I'm okay with it yeah I
think we found the one that that gets me
out of the Dead
um okay so maybe you can set it up and
you can kind of explain where you got
this position for and then we could do a
timer we can think quietly and then
we'll do as you said I can I can come up
with what I said and then you could you
could explain it so the first position
is not remarkable I got it from the
chess.com tactics page I set the rating
range from 2 800 to 3000 so it's a
slightly more complex chess.com warm-up
puzzle and then the next four positions
I took from a very underrated book I
think which is bides varetsky and Yusuf
of it's called chest tests and it's a
compilation of sort of unusual tactical
positions that build up originality of
thinking and obviously all of the usual
stuff like calculation but let's start
with kind of a warm-up type position to
get into the groove and then we'll get
to the divertsky positions afterwards
here it's black to play and like in all
the chess.com puzzles it's black to plan
ultimately win win decisive amount of
material
okay
um so should we pause maybe I might I
would like two minutes but we could do
one minute as well two minute is great
no I trust me I like thinking so really
as long as you need
okay okay
um so I will just
think quietly I guess
sure I can do the same okay so chat you
guys also have two minutes you could try
to think um do you want me to put a
timer I can put my that would be awesome
we can do this like a professional
Soviet you know training team yeah yeah
okay
chat you guys have two minutes on your
marks get set
go
all right time's up
man this is a tricky one
yeah
I'm glad you're seeing that too that
makes me think I didn't find it
correctly but I will I will explained my
thought process and I'm curious to see
how you thought about it okay
um so I'm going to start a little more
generally just because I think it helps
set it up and then I'll go into the
specific moves if you think it's too
slow just give me feedback and we could
adjust sure okay so what I notice here
it is equal material but white has the C
Pawn that they are trying to promote at
the same time black has this pin on The
Rook on H1 and the white king is in the
center of the board and there are
chances to potentially check me in two
minutes I only really had the the time
to explore two different ideas and they
were related to either trying to
Checkmate the king or trying to stop the
pawn because if we could at least stop
that I have a decent position
um so the moves that I came up with that
I liked the best were E5 and Knight A5
with E5 I've mostly just calculated C7
and Bishop takes E5
I thought that after E5 C7
um there is a variation where you
probably can end up checkmating the
white king and now I'm trying to look
and remember it
um and I'm not really seeing it so maybe
it was wrong so let's go to my next idea
my next idea was Knight A5 and the idea
was that you're threatening C6 and
you're also threatening Knight C4 which
would win the rook and then the bishop
is protecting the C8 Square so you could
sack that later if you need to
um
and then after Knight A5 there were some
lines like what if he plays King E2 then
maybe I go Rook B1 and that was about
the depth of things that I was looking
at so I will pause here because my chat
keeps spamming that you're looking
confused no no I'm I'm actually like the
funny the thing is I can't help myself
because as you're talking I'm like
simultaneously calculating the moves
that you're saying
um so I think our thought process was
similar initially I noticed three things
of course the vulnerability of the king
so there might be some mating Nets the
pawn on C6 but I was also very attracted
to the prospect of winning the bishop on
F1
um and to this end like the move that
occurred to me quickly was Bishop D3 it
doesn't work uh because after Bishop
takes D3 Rook takes H1 C7 uh I noticed
that the bishop on B2 stops the the C1
Square so whatever like sequence uh we
come up with I I figure that you're
gonna have to like check C7 to make sure
that the pawn isn't slipping through the
cracks
um I did come up with E5 as well as a
way to defend F4 but I did not see a
Checkmate after C7
and I also thought that after E5 maybe
white can play a move like F3 and create
a lift score for the king yeah I
actually thought of F3 as well which is
why I stopped looking at
looking at but it wasn't initially what
I considered yeah so then I sort of
transitioned back to the prospect of
winning the bishop and I realized that
there's this move Knight B3 to D2 which
I thought made sense because you leave
the bishop to protect the promotion
Square
but I thought Knight D2 white has King
E2 and I think this just refutes the
line immediately yeah because you said
this too but to be honest I saw chat
spamming Knight D2 so I looked at it and
then after King E2 I also couldn't see a
continuation you saw Chad spamming so
you knew it wasn't the move yeah yeah
so then I thought maybe we can start
with that was unnecessarily catching
Strays then I thought maybe rookie one
check is a better way to start because
wherever the King goes then I thought
Knight D2 would be guaranteed to pick up
the bishop but I'll tell you what
stunned me so King F3 Knight D2 is just
like a check and that's bad I thought
white has to play King F4
then I thought after Knight D2 there was
one tactic that I just could not for the
life of me find a response to I thought
white has this crazy move Bishop D3
um and by the way I'm making moves on
the board like we can also do this in
our head I I don't know like how we'll
end up deciding to do it
was on the board as
okay I agreed for the content yeah
yeah
and so here I thought after Rook takes
H1 Bishop takes F5 I think I probably
spent like 45 seconds on this position
and couldn't find anything convincing
because gfc7 and white wins I thought
maybe Knight to C4 to try to stop the
pawn but again white plays C7 and then
white promotes and white has two Bishops
for The Rook so that's kind of where I
was stuck um after Bishop D3
interesting
um okay
it's it's actually helpful to know that
you also had trouble solving it until
the end in two minutes yes 100 to get a
lot more in depth that's for sure and
you're able to just discount certain
moves there's something interesting I
noticed which is that I think you spent
more energy trying to design a mating
net I will say that I spent maybe like
20 seconds thinking about it but I
couldn't find even a hypothetical mating
net and to me that's a huge deal breaker
like if I'm attracted to the possibility
of mate I'll ask myself okay is there
some sort of hypothetical Target mating
position and even if you get like
three moves it's actually like almost
impossible to set up a mating position
like unless I'm missing something that's
actually a tip I usually give to my
students when they're trying to come up
with a plan it's like okay if you can't
come up with a plan in this position try
making three moves in a row yeah you
should help guide to see if something
like that would make sense and if you
can't do that with Checkmate then that's
that's a quick way to discount it I like
that I think it's an underrated tool
when you're trying to figure out is
there actually a mating net
um so I actually I'm pretty confident
that rookie one is the first move this
just seems like it moves in the right
direction so maybe we can take five here
E5 check
so if Bishop E5 you have rookie four
mm-hmm
so let's make the move on the board
King F3 is still 92.
so I guess white probably has to go King
G3
I think we're getting somewhere there oh
but now there's Knight D2
isn't there
um
and then after Bishop D3 which was the
initial problem
another like quick tip and not to
pretend like I'm you know I have all the
secrets to solving positions but we know
you have all the secrets so just tell us
so I think a lot of players
um they test out an option and it
doesn't work and they forget to test it
in a position that features a outwardly
imperceptible difference but you have to
manually retest like the same lines
because some difference that you think
might be unimportant might actually be
integral to your defensive capabilities
as it is here like you have to manually
look at that position again
and here of course I'm seeing that black
as a defense after C7 oh yeah course
well now I see it too because you put it
on the board so this is going to be my
contribution if you play C7 you have 94
check the king's gotta move somewhere
and then you play Knight D6 so the whole
difference is because the King was back
on G3 you get this extra move and I
guess what you'd need to check then is
was there any other option for where the
king could go in this position that
would escape the night but the only
option is G5 and G3 so you'd get that
check in in both of the options also
your contribution was the main move of
this solution if it is the solution
which is E5 so don't sell yourself sure
if it is yes if it is
um and for this one we'll have to check
it with the engine
um for the other positions I have the
solution in the book but we can also use
the engine I think you haven't seen you
haven't seen the other no no I I
literally just found them today and I
checked that um
you know that they were in the book and
everything but I had never seen those
positions before
so I think that's probably the solution
the one other thing I'd point out here
is that another bonus of playing E5 is
that Bishop C3 you don't have to bog
yourself down with Rook takes F1 you can
actually just pick up the dark squared
Bishop with 94. mm-hmm so I'm pretty
sure that that might be the sequence
shall we
check our first solution of the series
and probably end up being wrong yeah
let's check it but before we do I just
kind of want to summarize the way you
thought about it were you just looking
at moves really quickly so first you
checked to see if there was any kind of
mating net and then you just started
looking at ideas related to the pin and
then you were just coming up with
multiple moves for it right yeah like I
the first category are immediate most
moves that first order threads can you
attack the bishop so that 92 Bishop D3
belonged to the category but both moves
are easier to refute then like second
category moves are ideas that involve a
setup move or an introductory move that
Wards off the potential defenses and
rookie16 is the only like Rook B1
occurred to me also but I didn't see the
point of that I'm like what does it do
what is moving the dark squared Bishop
actually how does that help it actually
hurts because we don't have Knight D2
and by process of elimination this is
like the only other move that you could
throw in
got it
okay that makes sense
um I I like the way you thought of that
now let's check the solution oh God
doesn't be embarrassing now my excuse in
advance is that you know I've had a long
day
okay let's see
um rookie one check is correct
but it appears uh oh
E5 is incorrect Knight D2 immediately is
the move oh Bishop D3 and now E5 check
huh
so this is the move let's see what
happens if we try the other move order
yeah
if we try the other move order E5 check
there is
here black is better here so this is not
we didn't totally flame out king G5
Knight D2
oh my God okay there's a crazy computer
move and it's the only move to save the
game
and that move and to me this move is
unfindable it's G4
damn
it's G4
so what is the point of this move it
there's two points black it white is
preparing Bishop G2 to protect the Rook
and counter-attacking Black's bishop and
if Bishop E4 then suddenly white can
double back and go C7 again because
we've lost contact with the promotion
Square
right and then let's say that we move
the bishop to C8 because you you have to
move your Bishop away here G2 check
first yeah yeah then you just get out of
it
black is better after 94 check it's
around plus one
but by changing the move order we avoid
this option
that's so crazy that is actually hard to
find I was not expecting this to be this
hard I the range was like 2 800 to 3 000
and I'll say that that rating range I
usually solve about like five out of six
correct so this was pretty wild
um I'm just curious like why didn't I
consider E5 check I guess it was just
because at least for me The Rook is
hanging so Rook takes H1 seems
completely forced
but it's not
also it's crazy that Rook takes H1 is
still winning for black because you did
look at that that calc at that line as
well right
yeah apparently it is still winning for
black
after Bishop takes F5 and you can play
E5 even then but what is the actual
point of E5 it's not just to get the
king onto one of these squares so that
the Knight can come back after Bishop
takes E5 the point is that
here you can stop the pawn from behind
with the Rook
and what happens if white doesn't
doesn't take the bishop here
um I guess what are the other options I
think only only C7 that's the bishop
then you're still protecting C8
yeah so for example if white plays C7 I
think you can even just go Rook C1 and
ignore the tension right
and white just has no way to reinforce
that square I guess Bishop A6 but
White's not threatening anything because
black has two Defenders on this
and black is gonna consolidate here
somehow with maybe F6
interesting so so I I guess the reason
why you've
you felt like you ever looked it is
because Rook takes H1 was much more of a
natural move
uh earlier yeah instead of E5 I just
didn't put the ideas together I also
think this is a tactical weakness of
mine this is not the first time I've
noticed this I tend to miss intermediate
Moves In general especially in
situations where there's like a
compelling reason to not look for one
like Rook takes H1 just seems completely
forced but I knew that the check was an
idea in an earlier position so I guess
the idea is to combine
um combine ideas and not to forget to
check for the same move in like several
different types of positions but I would
argue Alex that E5 in the position we
wanted to play it would probably win
most games this G4 defense is pretty
crazy yeah do we get partial credit I
think we should give ourselves partial
gray we also found the first move
we did we well you did but we'll take it
well you found the main idea
yeah for sure since we're like learning
on this format it could be good oh yeah
and this is like a trial session right
we'll we'll optimize this we'll figure
this out so give us some time
all right this is your moment chat where
we are paying attention to you guys so
if you have a question put it in there
um
okay it's it's a lot of troll questions
so far
yeah I have a couple from my chat but we
can defer to your chat first
I have some troll questions too
uh
-huh
okay the question should be on theme
folks like about this position
I'm gonna try to see some
I'm gonna
let's see would you have found a G4 in a
classical game with white I think with
30 minutes in that position probably
um although not not even a given it's a
hard move
um
okay I think some of these are very
general questions and they're not
specific
um
I'm getting why not rookie fourcheck and
move two
okay let's look
I think the reason is King to G3 I don't
understand what this check does I I
think this also
said earlier so like if the Chatter's
act let's say the King goes to G3 that
would help you Checkmate so you have two
more free moves
um I don't see any way to Checkmate
because h5h4 he has the Escape Square so
that's not fast enough I guess there
there's Knight D2 though
yeah but that would be four I guess
that'd be multiple moves if oh yeah very
far away it feels very slow and remember
that when you're trying to mate the king
in this type of end game like white can
play a single move like F3 and get a
Luft Square so you're just like not and
Rook G4 check maybe was attracting
people but the king is dodging all of
the checks like I don't see where this
is going like Knight C4 Bishop takes C4
Rogue defends the bishop I don't think
this is going in a promising direction
for black
yeah agreed
um
so
okay all right well I I think I think
we're we're good with this because a lot
of them are our specific first moves
which I think if anyone has specific
first moves you could honestly try
copying this position and and testing it
out because I think that's one thing you
really need to do for practice is
actually put them on your board and and
try it yourself
and I think like engaging with the
position and understanding the intuition
behind wrong moves is really important
like if you come up with a move and you
feel very strongly about it and it's
wrong
you know you can trust us that it's
wrong the key is to figure out what
attracted you about this move because
that is often indicative
yeah that's often indicative of things
that you tend to prioritize wrongly or
things that you tend to assume or take
for granted uh or not prioritize enough
uh that might stand in the way of like
the right solution
okay I think that's that's a good point
um all right should we try the next one
let's try the next one okay so I'm
actually gonna choose this one not a lot
of pieces on the board so hopefully this
one will be
findable
we need some confidence okay I'm going
to add game
add game add game okay
and we're gonna flip the board it's
black to play here as well a lot of
black to moves today no particular
reason why so
and we don't have the evaluation so we
don't know if we're trying to win or
Draw which makes it harder but also
makes it more fun
oh for sure
so yeah it was so much fun it's not like
my chest coach let's have some fun yeah
which means
it's fun time yeah black to play okay
all right I'm gonna start the timer all
right everybody in chat put on your your
thinking
focus and uh one two three go
okay I think I got it
I mean sorry good job
you want a medal now let me think yeah
congrats congrats
all right time is up
okay
enlighten me
so I'm gonna start once again generally
what do you notice about this position
we are down a bishop but what we do have
going for us is that this Pawn is close
to promoting and our rook and queen are
cornering the white king also I don't
see any instant checkmates for white
even though our King is out in the open
so that's a decent start are we supposed
to be winning this are we supposed to be
drawing it I would be happy with a draw
being down this much material
um but of course it's an aggressive
position so I was trying to look at
tactics
um
the move that I liked the most was Queen
E3 I tried to look at Rook takes G2 but
I I didn't see anything after you just
give a queen for free
um I tried to look if there was any
difference between Queenie 3 Queen E5
putting pressure on the bishop
Queen E3 seemed to be a little bit
better because it was closer to the king
I tried to see if I play a move like
Queen E3 are there any threats I need to
be worried about but all of the checks
on B7 or A7 seems like I could just uh
sorry A7 is a free Queen B7 for white I
could just run away to H6 so that seems
okay but my issue with
um Queen E3 is after Bishop D1 I
couldn't really see a continuation
Queenie one looks good if Rook takes and
you trade off actually I'll play it on
the boards let's see Jersey I was
looking at Queen E3 Bishop D1 Queen E1
obviously white is not going to take the
queen because then you are better off
but white can just kind of sit on this
position
um
and I didn't know how to progress from
here so I just kept running through
multiple lines this is the one I I liked
the best but I just didn't have enough
time to see it all the way through
yeah and we can totally like in the
future adjust thinking time and and do
more time like I wouldn't mind that at
all
um so I started with some of the same
considerations which is that black is
down a piece within a couple of moments
I determined for myself that probably
black is trying to draw just because
like in order to win this you're gonna
have to either somehow Checkmate on G2
and it seemed pretty clear that there's
no way to do that I mean D1 Bishop takes
D1 there's no way to distract The Rook
um my next candidate move was also Queen
E3 and I got stumped after Bishop D1
similarly because again I think thinking
in like hypothetical ideal scenarios is
really good here like if everything goes
right for black how would we win and I
didn't even see an idealized version of
this like if white just sits
oh and White's not gonna say White's
gonna go like Queen D6 and stuff yeah
and it just seemed this just seemed too
muddy for me and it seemed pretty
certain that white was going to somehow
consolidate yeah like Queen D3 Etc like
you were saying
so then I was like okay what am I
missing are there any ideas that I might
be closing myself off to and that's kind
of when I spotted the correct what I
think is the correct move I'm not gonna
you know I'm not gonna say anything for
sure
um I look at Black's Rook Queen and pawn
and I noticed that all of them can be
given away basically on demand so I came
up with like a stalemate idea
um and a stalemate construction would be
the black king on H6
the white Rook on G2 and the white
Bishop controlling the king's only
Escape Square down the H file
wow
wow so that's when I came up with
did I play what queen G3
well Queen's already on G3
uh
no I see the bishop on D1
Oh you mean in this position yeah yeah
no but I thought in the initial position
oh okay
yeah that makes sense in the initial
position at first I thought about Rook
takes G2 Rook takes G2 D1 Queen Bishop
D1 and King H6 mm-hmm and this is
stalemate but I mean obviously white
doesn't have to take the queen
so I was thinking like okay Queen F1 and
I actually didn't see a way to force
stalemate here
right because if you take the Rook uh
you take back with the king and you
don't have to take what the queen makes
sense right but Queen H3 Rook H2 I think
is important I thought it was this at
first because King G1 Queen H1 is a
stalemate
but here there's the funny Rook H2 and
it's actually a pin against the king
yeah damn and you cannot take
but then I thought what if you change
the move order you don't have to give
away your pieces immediately after King
age six yeah exactly why does no checks
and I wasn't totally sure but I didn't
see a way for white to prevent there are
some like crazy lines here
I think Queen D3 might be the most
testing
uh response
and here there's a ridiculous idea I
think you can still promote
so I'll let you find the move after
Queen takes D1 or the sequence what's
the most clinical way to force dalemate
oh nice he takes and then Rook H2 and
I'll play it on the board as well for
chat so you take here it's forced you
have another Force check King takes and
now black has no moves
exactly still man oh that's sneaky
but then I got discouraged by Queen
takes G3 and even though the king is
stalemated it takes a second to actually
figure out the way to give away your
pieces
do you see
I think this is the only way
let me think
um but you could also take on G2
nice and if white doesn't take
um yeah so Queen takes King has to take
if you take on G2 and black the white
king moves away then you just take the
quake which is I think easy to forget
about If you're sort of missing the
forest for the trees yeah your black
simply wins
Wilbur 2810 said why
then why do shits always make you feel
so stupid hey this is hard I didn't even
I didn't in two minutes get to see the
stalemate idea yet but I had already
started seeing that there was no other
solution so I think with more time maybe
I could have found it but it's it's cool
how quick you realize that was the only
way
I mean it's largely an intuitive
judgment because there's a bunch of
candidate moves here that I didn't check
that could potentially be the solution
for instance I don't know like moving
The Rook back and playing Queen E1 is an
option right and going Queen E5 but all
of those moves belong to the same
category and white always responds with
Bishop D1 so a lot of it I think is kind
of cutting corners intuitively but
that's a lot of what puzzle solving is
like you can't really model the
situation you get over the board you do
have to kind of cut corners and look for
the flashy solution sometimes
but we can check
that's one of the things that has a huge
difference between puzzles and real
games because obviously in Puzzles you
know you're trying to solve something do
you think there's a way that you could
study puzzles that's more applicable to
actual chess positions
so there's a few things I think these
puzzles are a little bit more realistic
because you don't know the evaluation
which is a big pet peeve like if I give
a puzzle to a student
they'll often be like okay are you
trying to win or Draw and you should
want positions where you don't know if
you're trying to win or Draw because you
don't know during a real game what you
want
um but some of the direct skis some of
the more complicated zaretsky puzzles
are so open-ended that you just like
don't know even if you're trying to get
an advantage you don't know if it's a
slight advantage or like a winning
Advantage so for our next session I have
these positions back home in my desktop
um I didn't bring them with me I have
some positions from a chess book on
evaluation which are more open-ended
it's not that there are tactics in every
one of them it's like there is a
solution there is a best move
but you have to part of the funnest to
evaluate the position and then figure
out whether the best move is positional
or tactical so those types of puzzles
are hard to come by but they do exist on
this episode of having fun with Dania
Dania gives you puzzles and you don't
know who wins
exactly someone in shag gave the name of
a book that I totally think we should
solve from called um it's called find
the best move or no it's called
um it's it's this 70s book by these two
GMS and Russian is called together with
the grand Masters I have it so we could
definitely solve some from that book and
they give you a multiple choice in each
puzzle which is super open-ended like
it's not and there are no like flashy
tactical Solutions it's all very
practical
okay no I mean I love how many books you
have um I'm I'm just gonna run to the
bathroom real quick but if you want to
say the next one I'll set up the next
one and I'll do the same so when you're
okay I will also run to the bathroom
afterwards
all right
okay so this one is white to move and we
don't know what's happening yeah yes
exactly
okay all right I'm gonna set the alarm
and then I will count us down
here we go I want to get further this
time
okay I think you shall
all right three two one
oh my God it's been two minutes and 20
seconds that's okay
I think I have it
but um I do not have it but I have it
set up
okay okay so that's promising look at
this position and it's exciting at first
because white is up an entire Rook
you're feeling good you got all you also
have this pass Pawn on H6 but then the
closer you look white is in serious
trouble
um black is threatening Rook takes B2
and there's a lot of problems here you
can't take the bishop on E5 because
Queen takes A2 it's gonna Checkmate you
also can't play D4 which looks very
promising because of Queen E2 I couldn't
figure out anything after that
um so I was you know seeing all the
problems with the position
um I was trying to look for for
defensive moves but if it was Black's
turn to move Rook takes B2 King C1 Queen
C6 is Checkmate so I started looking to
something like Queen D7 work is there
any sack Queen takes C7 is there
anything after D4 is there anything with
Rook D2 and changing the order with the
queen going on E2 so I kept looking at
all of these but I didn't see any
solution yet so that's where I got in
these these two minutes and 25. I think
you're extremely close again assuming
that my move is correct I think we
should first of all a lot of people in
the chat were
flipping out over this bishop at first
um so let's just show that this is
Checkmate in two moves right the ratsky
problems aren't usually that easy
so
I was freaking out we we basically went
down exactly the same thought process I
thought about D4 I thought about Queen
D7 just seems like it allows too many
mating options in fact Queen D7 I think
there's a really pretty mate with um
Rook C2 and queen A2 Queen B2 here I'll
play it out yeah we should we should
always play these out we should play it
out
yes okay yeah so this is the beautiful
me
so then I came up with an idea that
briefly really excited me but upon
closer inspection it's just trash which
is Queen to G7
oh I looked at this as well but it
doesn't it's hilarious because it
doesn't stop the actual maid threat yep
you got just Rook takes B2 so yeah that
doesn't do anything I'm gonna play it on
the board yeah definitely if King A1 you
take on A2 if King C1 you go to C6 so
sadly it doesn't work um but you can
explain why it excited you it excited me
because the idea of deflecting the
bishop is very promising if you get this
position I think blacks attack Fizzles
out and white might even be better uh
with the bond tying Down The Rook that
that I would love to get I even thought
about the double votes gambo with Queen
takes C7 check which is a serious Canada
by the way
I looked at this too what did you
conclude uh I concluded it didn't work
and why did I conclude that I think it
was just because of King takes
then I thought Bishop takes C5 and I go
back to B2
interesting I I thought Bishop takes C7
and then back to E5 is hard to deal with
okay okay yeah you just got the same
position but down a queen so we haven't
really made progress
yeah that's the
so that didn't work at this point I
start opening myself up to bizarre
options and I think you actually named
the move that I came up with D4 Queen E2
what I I'm so uh okay so there was
something after okay not after not after
but I think there is a way to take the
sting out of Queen E2
using the fact that white is up a rook
initially which always opens me up to
the possibility of giving a large chunk
of the material back to take the sting
out of the main series of threats
so what idea comes to mind based on that
okay so I'm
for d
ude I think it's me or Queenie too I
think it's made after Queen E2 if the
queen leads its mate yeah well I I did
think about Rook D2 yeah I think that's
it I mentioned this earlier but I didn't
see how Rook takes
um D4 Queen E2 wasn't winning
I thought Bishop A1 there and I didn't
see a direct check or Bishop C1 sorry
Bishop C1 might actually be winning for
white
okay so yeah I did not see the bishop
move after I I basically stopped my
analysis after Queen E2 and I thought
okay I think black is better
yeah I felt like when the Rook is
leading it's a lot less dangerous
another thing which is again this
question of hypothetical mating patterns
right when I looked at Queen E2 I saw
Bishop C1 and I asked myself well even
if you give block a couple moves there's
actually no way to set up the mate when
The Rook is in front of the queen
because Rook takes A2 what can white do
here
I mean white just takes the bishop yeah
and all of the mating squares are
protected I did think like Rook A5 but
clearly you can go Bishop B2 and black
is fizzling the attack is fizzling out
huh
I don't know I don't know why I still I
I think my intuition was wrong here I
just looked at it I was like oh wait no
black is gonna win here but I didn't go
deep enough to it so I just cut it cut
it off short I think that was one of the
mistakes I made interesting yeah I mean
I think process of elimination is super
powerful here because at some point
you're like well there's no other way to
defend against mate so I think it's
important to identify ideas that could
be promising under a different set of
circumstances like D4 it almost works if
only you can somehow damage the efficacy
of Black's second rank mating mechanism
I guess I could check it
um let's see if Rook D2 is the move
it is only move it is wow
The Rook takes D2 D4 and it's plus one
that's the evaluation black is supposed
to go
actually to
set up this threat and now Rook to C1
oh wow because then you can you give
your queen back to C2 exactly and white
is winning because there's some tricky
tricky puzzles yeah for sure really
they're really pretty
I think they're instructive and
definitely when we do our more
open-ended session it'll be less about
like oh we it's the right solution wrong
solution maybe there will be more like
qualitative learning I just figured this
is a good way to get us into sort into
the groove of it
I'm so Rook D2 only move
okay Rook D2
um and beautiful so then I guess after
Queen E2 let's just check that it was
Bishops yeah Bishop C1 you're saying
that Bishop C1 is the only move because
Bishop A1 doesn't work
no Bishop A1 and it isn't two Bishop
Bishop more intuitive though so that's
not surprising you just hit the rook and
also exactly I thought Bishop A1 there's
even Rook D1 check with a Perpetual
check
um
and you know it's like once you see
Bishop C1 you don't even need to go
deeper into Bishop A1 yeah yeah exactly
so Bishop C1 and the one line that was
sort of tricky that we looked at was
Rook takes A2
um and this is it this is actually the
exact line that you looked at and then
okay six and you just play Bishop P2
okay well you're right your line was
correct yeah there should be two and
what is winning nice
all right nice so you know what I don't
I I I don't feel too bad but the
interesting thing is that even if I had
more time I had just wrote off Rook D2
so quickly that it would have taken me a
while to come back I think that's the
problem when you're solving tactics and
you've just confidently said that a move
doesn't work but you don't check it all
the way through you're less likely to
come back and double check it and you
bring up a really interesting point I
think I do this a ton I actually go back
through the moves I've refuted like I'm
probably too many times
like if if a move is close like it
doesn't work but the margin is narrow
and I feel like wait I need to double
and triple check this sometimes that
helps me find intermediate moves or
moves like Rook D2 which you know are
good moves to you know to throw in
before making the move that you ruled
out
um so that kind of like constant search
sometimes it doesn't work the first or
second time but when you do the third
pass through suddenly it kind of occurs
to you
and also I love that chat is asking for
homework one time we should just have
like three positions that we're gonna
cover in the next video and give give
people homework I think that would be
great yeah and we probably would have
we'll have like a position left over
today uh that we can that we can do for
homework as well so don't worry Chad you
can sit with it and see if you find it
absolutely the whole three people who
are doing the homework are gonna get
excited
yeah like the two people who have like a
notebook and they're you know writing
down no it's great I love that chat is
super involved honestly it's you know we
could have done this off stream Alex but
I think we decided that it would be more
fun and more engaging and like yeah less
we'll be we'd be less prone to
perfectionism if we did it on stream I
know we probably would have recorded
this like three times by now but I also
like chat's feedback and seeing when
people get confused
oh yeah for sure when I when I come back
to Charlotte I'll do a little stream
where I show people my my like bad takes
on YouTube videos and all the expletives
that I start throwing in
like welcome everybody to the YouTube
videos no like my my attempts at
recording that resulted in like 10
seconds followed by a string of cuss
words
no I
I've read the same intro like 15 times
gotten upset and stopped filming
something
no I'll do the whole table slam like
welcome everybody or what I'll do is
I'll record two minutes realize that I
haven't even gotten past explaining the
format of the video
and just start slamming the table and
being like
yeah that should be your intro
I worked into some sort of an intro that
would be fun like it could be a good bit
big we only have 15 minutes left so
let's do another one okay let's do
another one
um so that chat has one more chance to
get it right black to play
okay black to play
I'm about to start the timer
ready go
thank you
okay it's been almost three minutes okay
Okay so
first generalizations were down upon
there might be some opportunities for
background Checkmate for white uh
there's all these ideas on H2 either
taking or queen E5 our Knight is under
attack
um we need to be careful about trading
because we're down upon it if we trade
pieces that's going to make it more
likely for white to win so then I
started going through a lot of move
options I looked at Queen E5 I looked at
Bishop takes H2 I looked at Queen H5
um I think I even looked at 95
and initially I thought Bishop takes H2
was interesting but then I looked if
King takes H2 Queen E5 and even if the
King goes back if I play Queen takes
actually I should just play it out we
said we're gonna that's great
calculation I I think that's an
important line
um this is the line that I realized
black is still worse because if you just
trade off everything there's Bishop E3
there's Bishop E3 here
and I didn't see how we were going to
save this pawn and I thought this would
be a losing end game and I even thought
okay what about Knight takes well
they're still Bishop E3 here and I
thought once again
um we're just making up losing a pawn
here it's not super exciting all right
um so that didn't work
the one that I was most looking at was
Queen E5 which I thought that White's
best response was Knight F3 wait but
what about Knight takes what if Knight
takes C6 sir sorry to cut you off I Oh I
thought Knight takes C6 yeah I didn't
even see an I take C6 yet okay because I
have just come back to this one but this
is honestly like the move I should have
considered first but but even Knight F3
and like you know whites up a pawn so it
doesn't feel like black achieves all
that much yeah no I mean exactly and you
can't that's why I had already ruled it
out because you take and then Queen
takes so I didn't think
E5 was good but I I thought you could
just take the bishop I had already
rolled it out
um
and then
again I was starting to run a queen H5 I
realized you could just move it away uh
actually actually I don't remember what
I had found for Queen H5 but I thought
even Knight F3 was fine so exactly what
I was thinking too same
and then now that I had tried all of
these forcing moves and I was starting
to run out of time I there's also Knight
takes C4 and things like Bishop E5 I
don't remember why I didn't like that
and then I was looking just at 95
because I couldn't really come up with
ideas and at least it was attacking A4
but this is basically where I got to
before the time was up which I think I
just need more time because these are
pretty hard for me yeah and I think I
think that's one thing that we can take
away we can definitely I think do we we
probably shouldn't be shy about taking
you know like five minutes or so
um just because of the format and this
will be a more realistic look into how
you know good players train
I think there's one other aspect of the
position assuming my move is correct
it like I changed my frame of reference
completely here because I started with
the same thoughts as you Queen E5
um Queen H5 I was very tempted by
because there's a pretty line here
um which is check here and then Bishop
takes H2 wins the queen
so I was attracted to this but then I
was like wait a second Knight F3 and
it's a complete dead end but then I
asked myself well what else could I be
missing about this position I think a
lot of times when we miss tactics it's
because in the first couple of seconds
we convince ourselves that the tactic or
the move has to exploit certain features
of the position here I think it's the H
Pawn in the back rank but I also noticed
that there was some like peace alignment
going on in the D file and the Queen on
D3 is undefended the Knight on D4 is
poorly defended so like the moment I
paid attention to that set of factors I
thought that I found like the set of two
candidate moves which accomplished the
same thing and from which I then chose
one move in particular so I'll let you
like ponder that for a second
I think it's a
yeah
um
I'm now thinking about things like Queen
D7 or queen d8 because they threaten uh
they threatened the bishop takes H2 idea
so you can't actually take here
so well they threatened it actually look
interesting they threatened something a
lot more scary than Bishop takes H2 like
if you play Queen D7 for instance and
white plays H3
what's the sort of the straightforward
winning move
just take the night and if white plays
Bishop E3 instead
and this I think I'm gonna just show
chat really for sure
um and if there's Bishop E3 instead uh
previous move oh previous move yeah
because this one's oh here here instead
of H3 instead of H3
um if you play this instead
um
I mean
let's see I guess you just play Bishop
C5 yes and you win a piece so yeah I
don't see anything better
so then it was a matter of comparing
Queen d8 and queen D7 and I think this
is a very underrated tool interest the
method of comparison where you like go
as in as much detail as possible and
make as many observations about what
separates these two moves and sometimes
that leads you directly to the correct
move so my choice was one of them I'm
curious like where your intuition goes
between Queen D7 Queen d8 I think one of
those moves allows white to squeeze a
lot of the construction
well it's funny because if it was a
Blitz game you just I would almost play
Queen D7 instinctively just because you
know it doesn't leave a Knight hanging
it seems a lot safer
um
let's see is there is there any
difference so let's say I play Queen d8
um
the night still can't take because
there's a check so that doesn't work uh
what other options can black can white
defend here
um
let's say Bishop D3
and then I play the same move Bishop C5
and what does this change
um
you can also comment it from the other
end which is that like if you take the
moves in a vacuum what is the physical
difference in Queen placement what
can you say about
how the D7 Square differs from the d8
square
well the d8 square can be attacked by
the White Knight
okay um the d8 squared can also be
attacked by the bishop because it's a
dark Square
hypothetically yes but there's also the
question of defended versus undefended
right
the D7 score is undefended the d8 square
is defended by the Knight right
true
so when you put the queen on an
undefended Square inherently it's more
vulnerable
so after Queen D7 Can you spot a
defensive resource for white in fact I
think there are probably several ways to
defend here
using the undefended nature of the queen
on D7
[Music]
do I just get out of check can I play
something like King H1
then I'll go Bishop C5 though
that's true okay so I can't let that
happen
um look more closely at the undefended
queen on D7
okay
oh can I just play Queen F5 exactly I
think you can Queen B5 I think is also
possible
okay that makes sense I didn't I didn't
think about those but that that that
does make
it's obvious once you see it yeah for
sure and that's with a lot of tactics
now Queen d8 the reason it's correct has
actually nothing to do with the fact
that this is defended it's more that
white doesn't have an equivalent move
with this queen so you get out of the
radius is
Queen
decide I'll just go Queen d a
and that's usually how I'm able to
differentiate between two two moves it's
when I'm being thorough in the
calculations
yeah thorough and like
I don't know there's just a certain
intuition
um and and there's certain assumptions I
think that you can make which will block
you from finding Queen F5 such as oh I
can never abandon the Knight I almost
never tell that to myself like oh this
type of move is never possible I because
it doesn't cost anything to manually
check it like I will manually check
Knight take C6 one more time and
manually check Bishop E3 it takes a lot
less to check these simple lines than it
seems and often it allows you to
discover hidden flaws in your
calculation it's like what we saw in the
first exercise right where
we throw in the move E5 check and then
we have to recalculate the line where we
take the Rook because then we have that
Knight maneuver to stop the pawn
so that's kind of what I would say yeah
Queen T8 I'm pretty sure is the solution
I'm checking
yeah
thunderous Applause this is the best
move
and now just GH
and black yes very cute so I I guess
what I could have done better is here is
it it actually came down to the
generalizations where all I was thinking
about was
down upon you don't want to trade H2
back rank but I actually didn't spot
this so I think I moved a little too
quickly from spotting all the general
things before actually going into
concrete lines hmm interesting would you
did it keeps asking why Bishop B4
doesn't work but we'll go back there
Bishop B4 immediately uh I think after
Queen d8
but that's a confusing question for
white yeah
when they met Bishop
Bishop you're here
uh-huh I guess there's no threat because
even you know the funny thing is even if
it was black to move
this is kind of hilarious but even if
white makes a pass move
like this is you're just still fine for
a white yeah I mean queenly 294 and
there's mate but I think white can
survive with Knight C6 yep
nice Queen E1 Queen F1 almost
there
but also white can play like Knight
takes C6 here
yeah
but okay sorry go go back to what you
were saying
um
yeah no I think uh I was wondering if
this idea resonated with you of like is
it true that you might have gotten
fixated on the H Pawn and the back rank
whereas the moment I think you notice
the alignment of pieces Queen d8 becomes
an easier move to 200 to like uncover
it's still not guaranteed but it gives
you a shot at finding it I think it's
also the time pressure where I know I
don't have that much time so then I
spend it on going deeper on some of the
ideas that might work instead of looking
for new ones whereas if let's say we had
10 minutes on this then I would just
check all of them
I think probably five minutes would be a
good happy medium for some of these more
tactical positions yeah five minutes is
more fair and I think one idea that I
just had is if we if you do five minutes
we can mute ourselves in the Discord
call and think aloud to our own chats
and then sort of reconvene and discuss
the the downside would be that people
would listen to like me and you say the
same thing more than once but I think it
would still be it would also not try to
solve it on their own
[Music]
that's true although you could mute the
stream I guess if you're a diligent
chatter and solve like that but
I'm trying both I'm
down to Magic you know the quote with
any good technology is indistinguishable
from Magic well watching a grand master
in his zone is very similar and I think
even for me sometimes it's intimidating
how quickly you solve things and when
there's such a huge gap it almost feels
unreachable do you have any advice
well first of all I appreciate it that
means a lot
um I think the key well there's two
things first is I think people in chess
training over rate and I'm not just
saying this over rate the concept of
like accuracy or I need to get a certain
amount of puzzles right forgetting that
the whole point of solving is to improve
an OTB chess there's no puzzle rating I
mean there is a puzzle rating but it
doesn't matter right so ultimately you
would rather get 10 puzzles in a row
wrong and learn from all of them than
get 10 easy puzzles right which is why I
think solving easy puzzles is almost a
useless form of of training because if
you can already identify those patterns
quickly you don't need to like train
them repeatedly I think it's much better
to do puzzles that are just outside the
zone of your comfort level because
that's where like the expansion of
thinking happens but hopefully what this
showed and I'm sure we'll do more of
this and you know you'll get better and
we'll get better at explaining our
thought processes and stuff but it's
that most of these puzzles if you got
them wrong it happened for a reason it
wasn't just like
I saw the same thing and you saw the
same thing and then somehow I just
randomly came up with the right move I
think it's actually a learnable skill in
the sense that you can optimize what you
think about
how you think about it and you can
really narrow and delve deep into like
where exactly did I get stuck or where
exactly was I making a false assumption
or what factors of the position did I
not pay enough attention to and it's
going to take you longer to arrive at
the same conclusions for a while but I
think it is a skill that can be like
actually learned step by step it's not
just about solving as many problems as
you can
it's also about breaking down and
building up the correct thought process
and hopefully that's that's one area
where this exercise will help and
and in terms of the the puzzles that are
just outside your comfort zone for
people who have a puzzle rating on
chess.com what rating would you
recommend that they train because like
for this one I think you said it was 2
800 to 3 000.
you for example for who for for you or
let's let's say somebody in chat has a
1400 puzzle rating or whatever it has an
X puzzle rating how much would you add
on top of that for people to train
I would like recommend a range that
something like plus 200 to plus 500 of
the their puzzle writing of their puzzle
writing like for 1400 uh you maybe can
consider doing 1700 to 2200 and maybe I
like doing one challenging one per day
so like let's say you do
12900 puzzle per day and you're gonna
get it wrong most of the time if you
give yourself a time limit which you
should
um but but that's like the learning
experience you're like no you know
you're probably gonna get wrong first of
all it feels great to get it right from
time to time but then you review the
solution and your goal is like pure
learning you're just trying to like
improve your thinking process and see if
you can figure out what thought process
would have led you to the solution
essentially
before we end because I know you have to
run so I don't want to make you late for
your dinner you're totally good I'm just
curious to see if that's what we did
today
leave okay
so my puzzle rating is 28.40.
so actually these were these are maybe
maybe closer to the range but but two
minutes for me is just hard yeah I think
for next time we can definitely do like
at least three minutes maybe up to five
minutes of thought
okay and um we can also do a different
set of positions like some somewhat more
open-ended where we can really like
discuss and analyze for a while and
that'll be the Crux of how we arrive at
certain conclusions
okay well
on my own me too this was super it's
really always fun for me to let you know
to really
test myself on whether I can explain my
thought process and also these are not
easy for me contrary to what people I
think think like I actually am thinking
I'm not simulating you know I think I'm
actually calculating and stuff so and as
we could see like I don't get everything
right but Alice this was a real pleasure
um and I hopefully this is the start of
a tradition so I'm I'm super pumped
about this
sounds good Dania well I'll let you go
enjoy La send your family my love thank
you I'm looking forward to doing more of
these I will and I'll send you the raid
okay I appreciate it I'll send goodbye
to my stream have a great rest of your
stream Alex thanks again YouTube thanks
bye
all right guys well I hope you enjoyed
that um
session this is again just like the
start hopefully we'll get into the
groove but that seemed I mean I had a
lot of fun
um I feel like this is a promising
direction of content just the idea of
mutual analysis and you know us learning
each other's thought processes to help
grow
um so that's the session all right folks
I'm gonna head out I'm going to play a
little bit a little bit of Blitz off
stream
hope you enjoyed the stream and uh I'll
see everybody soon learning a little bit
of Chess yeah learning chess is good
also a reminder for everyone to drink
water don't get dehydrated or you'll get
migraines like I do so I'm just drink my
water real quick
foreign
[Music]